hey everybody welcome to metaphysical
milkshake i am rayne wilson and i'm reza
aslan yes you are and hey reza aslan
how long have we been friends uh let's
see i guess i'm gonna say like 2013 so
maybe like eight wow [ __ ] eight years
that's a long time and you know what uh
occurred to me and thinking about that
we have yet to have a man weekend
together i i don't know what a man
weekend is you know like a couple of
guys camping out in a tent together
nothing but the sun on our faces
the wind and our hairy backs
and like wi-fi right like no man not on
a man weekend
the only wi-fi is is the song of the
birds chirping just you and me out in
the open in the woods peeing and pooping
i'm not sure
is this is this truly what men do come
on let's hit the open road come on let's
find a patch of dirt and wrestle in the
mud together for like 14 hours like real
men listen i look i love nature i'm not
saying i don't love nature but you got
to understand something about immigrants
is that we don't understand the whole
american obsession with camping because
we're like
but you have a home and a bed
why would you sleep outside on the
ground i did that because i had to yeah
but this is what men do okay they go
camping okay so
embrace it you sound exactly like a guy
who runs a farm with pigs and zonkies
okay i i on the other hand
you know i prefer like a nice
comfortable bed that's all well that's a
shame because you know what uh reza
truth be told when i'm out in nature i
just i learn a lot about myself yeah
being in nature teaches you about being
human yeah i think it can so i'm gonna
mark you down for next weekend
all right fine but but as long as
we bring some toilet paper because i am
not using leaves
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
so you know this is a interesting topic
what what can nature teach us about
being human and you know what
i think i've got just the perfect person
to help us crack this nut my dear friend
and comedic doppelganger
nick offerman oh shut up you don't know
nick offerman yes i do no i know
but he's famous and stuff yes the
brilliant actor author and woodworker
he's right here ron swanson from parks
and rec
amongst dozens of other brilliant roles
new york times best-selling author right
here right now let's do this fun facts
he's from manuka illinois he's written
five semi-autobiographical books he is
married to the comic titan megan malali
hey nick offerman this is incredible wow
uh thank you for coming on metaphysical
milkshake my pleasure it's about time
can i call you nick or do i have to call
you mr offerman please call me nick okay
thanks i feel like i feel like we're
friends yeah i was talking to nick the
other day oh nick offerman yeah and um
you know author of um where the deer and
the antelope play by the way is the
longest title how did dutton let you
keep the title where the deer and the
antelope play the pastoral observations
of one ignorant american who loves to
walk outside they make me do the
subtitles i always
i always ask for just the title like my
earlier titles are like paddle your own
canoe gumption
and they all they're always like
we need the consumer to be spoon-fed
what the book is
so nick welcome to the show this new
book i have truth be told i haven't
finished it i'm about halfway through um
and i've thumbed through the rest of it
but um it's incredible it's so good um i
was telling you earlier i think you're
just absolutely hitting your stride as a
writer you're you've always been great
from paddle your own canoe your
autobiography to gumption to the
woodworking book um all of the different
books you've written but you're finding
your voice you're like the voice of of
like you're this american male voice of
a certain generation who likes to eat
you know a cheeseburger and loves a good
babbling brook
and also is a big fan of mounty python
like you're you're just square in this
certain zeitgeist that you have kind of
created yourself
before we this isn't even on our list of
questions of approved questions before
we get going like that how have you
what what happened did you ever think
that you would be a multi-award-winning
best-selling author of all things no i
mean i i went to theater school i just
wanted to get good parts and plays in
chicago that was my dream
uh my dream career and then
organically things just you know then i
uh began building scenery and
uh i got a little job here and there and
you know then i
moved to la worked in tv and film
and it was such a weird thing it was
because
from parks and recreation college
colleges began to mistakenly invite me
to perform my stand-up
and it and at first i i had to say oh i
don't do that i'm a theater actor but
after a few invitations i said wait a
second talk to 2 000 college kids for a
very nice uh paycheck
yes please tell ohio state i'll come do
my stand up so i started writing you
know stand up but i don't write jokes
per se so i always call myself a
humorist
because i do make people laugh but not
because of my incredible like zach
galifianakis type wit
it has something more to do with my
delivery or my cadence or something
and so then that uh led to books and i i
never in a million years dreamed i'd be
talking to you guys about my fifth book
[Laughter]
unbelievable that's more than reza yeah
i'm i just turned in my sixth book so
thanks there's quality and there's
quantity
before we go forward you know i think
folks deserve to know a little bit about
our history um which when i tell people
it kind of blows their minds like you
and i used to knock around in all of the
same audition rooms and our story is so
parallel it's so in line i i went to
theater school for the same thing i just
wanted to get good parts in new york
you know and and then i kind of realized
oh wow all of these tv actors have done
like one sitcom and then they come back
and they get cast as mercutio and romeo
and juliet at the public you know the
only way i'm gonna get to play mercutio
is if i go to a sitcom so then i hauled
my
weird little white ass over to la and we
came at around the same time i was there
in 2000 is that when you showed up
i got here a little earlier like 97 98
okay and that's when you met and and
coupled with megan malali yes i spent a
couple years trying to find my ass with
both hands kind of kicking around
figuring out
why the hell i moved from the best
theater town in the country chicago
to
uh the largest collection of actors and
writers and directors but really a
pretty mediocre theater town because
everybody's focused on on the ulterior
motive of tv and film here
um
i'm
but i'm surprised i would have thought
that i had met you a little earlier but
if it was 2000
it's it's really interesting we uh
when an audition would come in and you
get the description of the role called
the breakdown
uh i began to be able to discern if i
would see you or not like if the
if the character
was a basement dweller
or yep or quite often like
creepy suspicious guy
yeah weird creepy offbeat but yeah we uh
we really ran into each other
enough that uh i considered you a friend
oh this is a true story
for the first like three or four weeks
of doing this podcast i thought i was
doing it with nick offerman
it's only about like second month in i
was like oh oh no it's rain wilson right
that's a fine compliment thank you
yeah because you know speaking of of
creepy basement dwellers i remember in
new york i once auditioned for tony
randall you know the famous actor from
the odd couple yeah and he was running a
theater company in new york and
i did my audition and i finished i
worked really hard on it i finished i
looked at him and he looked at me and he
goes
you should play baby-faced killers
and i was like well you got any babyface
killer roles yeah i'll take him he's
like unfortunately no all right let's
talk about the book it's it's so
interesting um both reza and i were
drawn to this one sentence uh that you
had put in here and i want to i want to
start with this uh
little
niblet of profundity from the offerman
offerman universe from the offerman
workshop
we must understand that we are not
passive passengers on this mothership
earth but instead we must participate in
the journey whether that means grabbing
an oar and helping to row or feeding the
crew or wholly stoning the decks no idea
what that means only then will we be
able to help steer this venerable vessel
away from the shopping mall
amazon.com and towards the woods and the
meadow and the back that's good writing
but this whole um book was born out of a
hike really and then a couple other
trips including one you took with your
wife megan and your dog these journeys
taken over the last two years and
through the pandemic kind of allow a
series of of digressions and we'll get
to some of those digressions uh coming
up but tell us how this whole thing
started well thank you first of all you
you've said some very nice things about
my writing and i appreciate it um it's
it's something that i work really hard
at and i
uh i can feel the improvement uh across
my books so it's very gratifying to hear
that from you smarties
um
i i've had the idea for this book for a
long time uh
ever since i became obsessed with the
writing of wendell berry in the mid-90s
uh who's my favorite agrarian writer
he's in his 80s he's a kentucky farmer
and he's wonderfully prolific he writes
fiction and essays and poetry
and
there's something about the common sense
in all of his writing
uh calling attention to
our human ignorance our proclivity
to turn a blind eye to our
responsibilities uh as as
you know
members
of the natural fellowship of the planet
uh we we have long since given away our
agency to corporations and say you guys
here's my money you send me electricity
send me uh running shoes and everything
in between
and i assume you're going to be cool
right
about the way that you
you procure these things and something
just really struck me uh
sort of seeing my own
donkey-like place
in in this churning machinery of
consumerism
and just realizing you know how
complicit we all are
know whether you're ed begley jr or you
know like the coolest of tree huggers
to
the the worst you know materialistic
like
yacht
driving cigar smoking like
music star or something
everybody is complicit in this system
and
uh i just
i don't feel like i have uh
you know i'm not a great fiction writer
i don't have like
vast great ideas
and so what i try to do is take these
sensibilities like like this agrarian
uh
our human fallibility in the eyes of the
of agrarianism
and get a laugh uh from my readers
saying
let me let's just focus on on this
this particular way in which we're
stupid
um
me included and if we if we talk about
it maybe we can ask some questions and
maybe we can continue to like
link arms and lurch
farther towards decency you know and by
the time we're done maybe uh
you know we'll
use less single use plastic bottles or
or
vote for uh
less voting restriction or you know
whatever
if i can swing seven people
over to to grass fed rotationally grazed
beef cows
then my job will be done here one thing
uh the third part of the book is really
fascinating this is when um
you and your wife megan get an uh
airstream
and and start like rolling across the
country uh rain and i both huge rv
fans uh rvs that's my that's my jam in
fact streaming uh we you know we we kind
of rent an rv every year and so last
year we decided we were going to buy an
rv but we decided to buy
uh a 40 year old rv this rv which was
built in 1984 literally in 1984 we were
like we're going to be the cool family
yeah oh yeah we're going to rebuild this
thing it's going to be so cool
we've owned it for
a year i think we've driven it maybe
once so far
and it's been in the shop ever since
then
did not in any way dampen our love for
the rv though no
hey folks do you identify as crypto
curious why yes if you've thought about
entering the world of cryptocurrency but
felt a little overwhelmed coinbase makes
learning to buy and sell simple i have a
coinbase account and i can vouch for it
if you've been following the
cryptocurrency craze now is the time to
start getting involved coinbase makes it
quick and easy to start your own
portfolio and learn to trade like a pro
and coinbase also offers a trusted and
easy to use platform so you can buy sell
and spend your cryptocurrency they
support the most popular digital
currencies on the market and make them
accessible to everyone they offer
portfolio management and protection
learning resources and a mobile app so
you can trade securely and monitor your
crypto all in one place millions of
people in over a hundred countries trust
coinbase with their digital assets
whether you're looking to diversify just
getting started or searching for a
better way to access crypto markets
start today with coinbase for a limited
time new users can get ten dollars on
free bitcoin when you sign up today at
coinbase.com milkshake
sign up at coinbase.com slash milkshake
for ten dollars in free bitcoin this
offer is for a limited time only so be
sure to sign up today that's
coinbase.com
milkshake today's program is brought to
you by athletic greens the health and
wellness company that makes
comprehensive daily nutrition really
really simple my wife and i begin
basically every morning with our
athletic greens i mean with so many
stressors in life it's difficult to
maintain effective nutritional habits
and you know give our bodies the
nutrients it needs to thrive athletic
greens gives you it gives you a lot of
things it gives you greens
you know like your veggies it gives you
vitamins
and it gives you a kind of a clarity and
an energy i love putting it in the
morning i shake it up it's got a little
bit of a lemony flavor it tastes
delicious and i just feel better
throughout the day and not in the script
but helps you poop wow this special
blend of high quality bio-available
ingredients in a scoop of ag-1 work
together to fill the nutritional gaps in
your diet it supports energy and focus
it aids with gut health and digestion
what did i say didn't i just say that
athletic greens is lifestyle friendly
whether you eat keto paleo vegan dairy
free or gluten-free it contains less
than one gram of sugar no gmos no nasty
chemicals or artificial anything and it
tastes great so join the movement of
athletes lifeleads moms dads rookies
first timers podcasters and everyone in
between take ownership of your daily
health and focus on the nutritional
products that you really need in the
simplest manner possible and to make it
easy athletic greens is going to give
you an immune supporting free one year
supply of vitamin d and five free travel
packs with your first purchase if you
visit athleticgreens.com
milkshake today again simply visit
athleticgreens.com
milkshake and you can take control of
your health and give ag-1 a try
so what is what is this like this this
like quintessentially american
experience of the rv you know there's
something there's something about it
it's like it's it's it's in our blood as
americans and is it is it terrible
you're talking about like saving the
earth and making smarter decisions and
here we are talking about giant buying
ginormous
three-cylinder
uh
gas guzzling diesel spewing
monstrosities and driving them through
nature meanwhile i'm getting eight miles
a gallon on this thing exactly i mean
literally eight miles a gallon and i do
i do i am self-effacing about that in
the book because
uh we're that's kind of what i mean
we're all complicit in this way where
we're we're stuck in this system where
not only are we are we hauling rvs you
know
like get your get yourself to yosemite
uh and everybody has to take their you
know their own vehicle and burn all
these fossil fuels to do so
and
it's it's
part of uh what i want to point out is
that there's there's it's not a binary
question i i talk a lot in the book
about how all these conversations
require nuance and i think that
if if we can
start by admitting our human fallibility
and saying of course we're humans like i
i make mistakes every day i'm a [ __ ]
farting you know mammal
doing my best to like live with empathy
and decency and responsibility but i'm
human i'm going to also like give in to
whatever weakness uh comes up on the
wheel that day
and so finding a balance uh
starts with admitting that fallibility
and if we can do that as a society and
say well yes of course we had slavery of
course we
had genocide and etc and misogyny and
homophobia and you name it of course we
have those things and they're
understandable things they're animal
reactions
but we can now recognize that they're
wrong you know that they're that they're
not right and that we should strive to
do better if we
there's nothing shameful about any of
that like yes i
ate too much pizza and vomited in the
bed honey like i can admit that it's
totally wrong but you can understand
oh you got a understanding wife and so
with that in mind i i want to say look
yes we're all the amount of vehicles and
firearms in this country is so
astonishing and and bananas
but we all are are ensconced in it and
say okay
we are coming around to understanding
this is terribly wrong
let's let's
whether we're in our rvs or we're living
in a yurt or wherever we're doing let's
focus uh our attention on solving these
problems
so that we can still someday go to
yosemite but not burn eight gallons of
gas uh
per mile this love of nature and the
outdoors is this something that you've
always had did you grow up
with this um kind of appreciation
of the wilderness
i did i don't feel like uh any sort of
terrific outdoorsman or outdoors person
uh
i mean my family uh all grew up on farms
and half of them still farm in this
little town
and our main thing we do is go fishing
uh we spend a lot of time outside but
it's all sort of affordable working
class recreation uh each household has a
fishing boat
um a couple of the more action-oriented
households also do like water skiing and
you know
uh snowmobiling and stuff like that
but by and large
uh i you know i i don't feel like um
people sometimes are like oh you should
get together with bear grylls or or
other sort of outdoor survivalist types
and i say no i'm a i'm a soft ass actor
living in los angeles and i love to walk
in the woods and like look at a tree i i
i couldn't tell you uh which herbs we
should eat to survive you know like
but but i would love to go sit and and
find out with you um
so i just always grew i don't know
something about my placid demeanor is
fueled by uh being able to just go for a
walk
and and
take in whatever the ecosystem has to
offer there's a lot of themes that are
interwoven through this story that
starts with this very simple hike of you
and jeff tweedy from the band wilco and
george saunders the you know incredible
american uh author and your shared love
of taking these walks in the woods this
is kind of the springboard for the story
and you you you veer i love the way you
write this because you veer off and all
of these digressions that kind of it's
almost dream of consciousness like i'm
walking down the trail and i'm
thinking about the black fit indians
that used to walk down the same trail at
glacier national monument but you know
now we have all these native american
mascots and and people are very upset
and then you kind of go down that trail
but there is one topic that you dig into
uh with great gusto uh throughout the
book especially in the first third and
that is
bears
and as you know i have a very special
connection to bears
um i have for a very long time both both
personally and professionally
nick
you are an you have become an expert on
bears what have you learned about bears
the main thing i learned in researching
and living the experiences that became
this book
is how to tell the difference between
black bears and grizzly bears
um and there's a few different
techniques by which you can you can make
this discernment
sure fill us in please my favorite was
uh if you see a bear
um climb up a tree to get a a good safe
look at it and and then watch its
behavior
uh
if it um
if it climbs up the tree and gets you
it's a black bear but if it stays on the
ground and shakes the tree
until you fall out of it then it's a
grizzly okay very good advice one of the
digressions you go into in the book
which i just loved and i got so much out
of reading um was our
incredible disconnection from the food
chain you want to talk about that theme
a little bit yeah i mean that's what
really hooked me in my my whole love of
the agrarian mindset is uh i come from a
farming family
and
when i first was reading wendell berry
it's it's the uh
it's the dignity that he that he lends
to the simple hard work that human
beings do to sustain ourselves and our
loved ones
like he wrote there's one passage in a
novel where he wrote about a farmer
mending a fence
and he wrote sort of
uh
so uh elegantly is that how you
pronounce that word
yes
it's not a legit i always pronounced it
allegically either one it was gorgeous
uh it was like he was describing a a
production of swan lake and it was about
this guy mending his fence and and it
brought me to tears because i realized
oh this guy is like making heroes of
regular humans of people who
just cook and like ra you know raise
kids and like grow a garden and maintain
their buildings etc
and
what struck me was then thinking about
where our food used to come from and
reading the books of michael pollan as
well
uh where we
where we begin to learn where all of our
food is sourced nowadays
uh which is usually some sort of of
corporate channel
so much of it is corn based and so much
of it is processed
and i realized holy cow
we used to at least make real food you
know we used to know where our food came
from it had necessarily had to be local
because of refrigeration but whether it
was your meat your dairy your produce
your fish
your fruit and vegetables
all of it you had some idea of what
these actual foods were and quite often
where they came from or who who produced
them
and nowadays even those of us that are
as healthy minded as possible you're
still really hard-pressed to discover
who's
who's growing your food who's creating
it
and that disconnect is so bizarre
because
we've handed our agency to corporations
well to our government
uh
or to corporations which is kind of a
redundant statement and we give them
we have given them tacit permission
to make our food in a way that is not
mainly concerned with our health
that's what knocked me over when i
realized
corporations have been lobbying for
decades for permission to make our food
less healthy so they can make more
profit i was like wait a second i
understand doing that with like an
automobile or a basketball
but you shouldn't be able to make your
sandwich worse for me
be so that you make money and and at the
cost of my health and my family's health
and so that's that's what really that's
the gas in my motor with this whole
topic is
is that
self-sus self uh respecting adults
how can we not
maintain a knowledge of where our food
is coming from who is who is uh raising
our food and
thereby how are they treating the planet
how are they treating our resources and
it's that you know when you think about
it in that way it's connected to
everything
that we produce as a species
uh and so suddenly you're in the midst
of of the environmental conundrum of
like how
how are we so
egregiously misusing this planet and her
treasures even the uh the big aggro
influenced the food pyramid right and
that's been documented yeah we grew up
with this food pyramid and the bottom
was like
grains you know it's like oh
wheat and soy and
um and and whatnot and and and actually
grains are not so good for you
especially if you're just having pasta
and bread all the time and lo and behold
we've got an obesity epidemic i was just
thinking as you were talking about the
food chain stuff i mean are you a hunter
nick do you hun i don't but i am a
fisherman and i i pride myself in
cleaning my own fish
it's you know something we've done
uh
as a an affordable sustainability
practice like my
family freezes we catch enough fish to
freeze and eat all year and there's a
couple uncles that hunt
um and i admire hunters that hunt to
feed their families or or hunt to
cull you know the deer population on
their ranch or what have you there are
healthy
i think admirable
ways to hunt
and then i despise trophy hunting i just
you know the like anything there are
ways to do it that are commendable and
there are ways that that are only
creating waste
and of course the the wasteful ways are
abhorrent when you were writing about um
you know our relationship to nature i
was thinking to myself how much of the
american identity
has been forged
precisely through that kind of early
european encounter
with the wilderness i remember as clear
as day the first time that i saw niagara
falls for instance
i thought to myself can you imagine
like lewis and clark
making a left turn and ending up at this
thing like
how crazy that experience would be for
all these europeans all these puritans
you know who came from this very
urbanized industrialized europe they
come to quote unquote the new world and
this place must look like some kind of
magical forest
to them i mean the entire kind of
encounter of these white settlers with
this kind of
unaltered nature this the you know the
the the land of god this was the
defining american experience and then at
the same time what i find really
fascinating about it is that
they
they encounter it with absolute awe
and then
their first thought is let's cut it all
down let's
let's just exploit the [ __ ] out of all
of this
uh i i read this uh article recently
that
uh
the redwoods right so imagine imagine
these europeans setting eyes on a
redwood for the first time
uh and being just absolutely i mean you
know this is this is the the glory of
god
uh
95
of the redwood were logged by the the
first europeans who settled in
california so well done
and that then becomes kind of the story
of america's relationship
to nature in a way that we define
ourselves in sort of rugged
individualism you know we are we are the
the people that that tamed tamed the
wild land the new world
but at the same time
we
almost instantly exploited it to our
advantage and we're still kind of we
still do that right that's still sort of
the way that we think about uh our
relationship to the natural world
absolutely i mean you uh make a great
point that we established this attitude
of dominion over nature that all of
nature exists for us to use and and
dispose of as we see fit and it also
fits into the manifest destiny policy of
our country where not only the forests
and the coal and the oceans and all of
the natural resources but also
the native american tribes like
that's also part of nature that we said
you know what the the african uh
population we said we will use this as
we see fit
because we have a book that was inspired
by our god that says
we deserve all this and we're still very
much trying to back ourselves out of
that you know idiotic fallacy it's like
whoa
no it's
like so much of our country you know
patriotism and uh
nationalism
that says like of course we're the
greatest country because we kill [ __ ]
better than anybody else
and when when you look at it that way
it's
for me anyway it's easy to say okay hang
on a second
the sort of rah-rah patriotism i grew up
with suddenly doesn't feel so clean um
maybe what what if
no country
was the best at killing each other what
if our country was the best at helping
each other what
what would that be like
very well said nick you know one of the
things i've just always admired about
you nick is and i kind of look at you in
a certain with a certain measure of awe
because you're such a genius actor but
you have this wood shop and you're able
to make a canoe and you're able to you
made my table you made my literally my
dining room table that we eat off of
every night about 12 years ago
and um i i'm a i can't make anything i'm
astonished at that and plus you're a
better writer than i am so
i just don't stack up but the point i'm
getting to is
you you walk this incredible
line with your masculinity because at
the same time as you're unabashedly um
a meat-eating
man's man fisherman canoe builder you're
so self-deprecating too and are
constantly questioning kind of the role
of masculinity in all this because you
know like reza said you know hey look
there's redwoods let's chop them down
and make make a buck off of them um
you know and that goes hand in hand with
like a real man would chop them down and
make a buck out of them because that's
what men do
so
conquering nature
masculinity
you know
you you have such insight in this you
walk this fine line between being this
kind of
brute and you're also part of you is a t
sipping
you know chamomile tea sip in
birkenstock wearing snowflake
on on this show we've had several
conversations about masculinity but tell
us like through this journey and
previous journeys how's your journey as
a as a white
cisgendered
you know
uh male
how has it uh evolved over the years
especially now in your relationship to
nature
it's interesting i mean i grew up very
much i was an athlete you know i
uh
i
grew up in a working-class family so i
had all the messaging of uh
of conventional in the 70s and 80s
masculinity and you know uh
conventional like
uh cis
relationships
um
and
i always felt you know uh i don't know i
didn't fit well into that
that exact paradigm which is first what
led me i think to become a theater actor
um
and and sort of explore like why does my
little conservative town feel so strange
everyone's very nice by and large
with there's a lot of great values here
but then at the same time once i got out
into the world and i said oh okay but
it's a calcified
super conservative like white christian
town and so long ago they are they
established
no people of color no
people that aren't straight etc and so
on
and so
it kind of took me by surprise
eventually when i started getting
any visibility uh as an actor and i got
accused uh pretty quickly of being
masculine
um or sometimes even macho and i was
like wow dad
where are you
where are you getting that i think it's
the voice nick
well it's the voice it's the mustache
when i have it
i am i understand in hindsight but but
what it pointed out immediately was how
superficial that estimation was
i was like oh no i'm a total like
i don't know weird
i don't know i don't feel like a badass
man
um
i can lift heavy things and i can i can
swing an axe and
but i don't think that's like
if you think that's what makes you manly
i think that's a fallacy uh
and it was interesting because then i
began to explore it and ask the question
because suddenly i had a platform and i
had
a following of of some sort
and i said you know i think what what
you're after
i don't think you there's any need to
put a gender on it um
whether we're talking about my wood shop
or my love of like grilling meat or what
whatever
there are men and women and
gender non-conforming people who love to
do all of those things i love to build a
house out of wood with my hands and my
strength i also love to sew a button
daintily onto my boxer shorts
and they they feel equally triumphant to
me they've all
are human beings using our ingenuity to
miraculously
make a beef wellington i mean
i i don't care you know what you're
carrying in your genes or what your
sexual identity is
we all should get to
to love
anything like that and i i feel like
anybody who makes a lot of noise about
masculinity
which
in this day and age often takes the
shape of like
working out or virility like i take take
my pills to make you virile
um
or there's even you know josh hawley a
shameful politician right now
is somehow accusing
the
liberals of uh
undercutting the nation's masculinity
all of those things just drip
for me with insecurity
um it's people who are terribly
frightened
that they're not
living up to this these superficial
uh
stereotypes that they somehow have been
taught
um
when really again i i always go back to
like i'm just a [ __ ] like
clumsy mammal
uh and i've found my niche of like okay
here's the things i can do well enough
to get paid and that buys us food in a
house and so i'm i'm feeling pretty good
but i
am centuries past needing to like
draw down a sword on somebody or like
you know
win any part of my life with with like
my strength
or my virility
um i think that's
dumb and i think that that's um
that
is a mask that makes it hard for us to
actually communicate
openly with with vulnerability how does
this relate to uh a modern american take
on our relationship with nature because
hasn't this relationship with nature
been just so corrupted by these faulty
ideas of masculinity
absolutely i mean i think it goes hand
in hand with the manifest destiny or or
man's dominion over nature which is a
christian sensibility that we've been
taught
uh which which basically gives the you
know the people lining their coffers
with profits
gives them permission
to exploit our resources you know
we uh
you see a forest you see a mountain full
of coal
we will [ __ ] that mountain we will we
will rip its skirt off and have our way
you know until we have consumed every
last nugget of coal or what have you
and
i mean you know
all of the all of the greatest
writing that i've enjoyed
always leans towards uh a matriarchal
sensibility
mother earth gaia herself you know is
uh all about
birth
and and harvest you know and and uh the
renewal of the seasons and and death and
decay it's all it's all a much more
feminine
uh
structure
and i and i think that
you know that the masculine approach is
is desperately trying to maintain power
where we shouldn't
the fundamental message of
your book
is that um
it's important for humans to commune
with nature and
obviously like we're in a situation now
where humans and americans
especially are becoming more and more
removed you know from nature more and
more removed from the outdoors in in
general and there's like a a very
serious consequence to this and i'm not
just talking about metaphysical
consequences or like spiritual
consequences those are those are true
but i mean like actual physical
consequences um
the the benefits that that you know
nature has on our health and our
well-being have been
exhaustively documented
being in nature decreases stress and the
number of
studies that show just even a 20-minute
walk
in nature reduces stress significantly
lowers heart rates
being in nature makes you happier
there's literally scientific studies
that have showed that
a brief walk through nature
allows you to experience less anxiety
less rumination
uh it instills you with more positive
emotions
being in nature relieves uh attention
fatigue it increases creativity it uh it
actually this is actually true there's a
series of of experiments published in
2014 that showed that being in nature
helps you be kind and generous
wow
so there are these like very real very
immediate
health and well-being benefits to
uh you know the experience of nature but
fact of the matter is is that you know
we're becoming more distant you know
from nature uh america is continuing to
sort of shift into a more like
industrialized more urban
environment so i guess my question
is like
what what does this mean for the future
of humanity
if we continue down this road and like
how how can we reverse that how can we
how can we create you know a generation
of of people who are who are just better
stewards of the environment that's a
huge question um
you got four minutes i mean i i think
this book should do it uh
i
assume that they're passing it around at
the at the cop26 in glasgow right now
i i feel like the answer to that
question is uh
i don't know that's
my objective uh
and wrapped in this in this humorous
multicolored book is to sort of
wake everyone up including myself
to the reminder that we're suckers
that uh we've allowed ourselves to lapse
into consumerism and and if and if the
you know money-making corporations if if
the billionaires have their way
we'll eventually just always remain in
our pods
and everything that we need will order
by pressing buttons
and then and it will all be provided by
uh by these companies
and the thing what you're saying
uh the thing i love about getting
outside
wherever it is is it's also free
um it's a way that you can live it's
it's meditative
uh you you are not harming anything so
whether you're hiking all day or just
going for a 20-minute walk or whatever
it is
that's time that you're not consuming
it's time you're not destroying anything
you're not
i mean i think there's a reason that it
makes us happy is because
we're not
doing anything negative to ourselves to
the planet or or to our
our fellow humans
you know
that reminds me of a story
we went to visit the great smoky
mountains um because my wife's
grandfather when he was alive he was a
precious human being he entered a
contest from pepperidge farm cookies
about national parks and how much he
loved national parks and which i think
he wrote an essay on which national park
he wanted to visit and he wanted to the
great smokies so the family got a trip
to the great smokies courtesy of
pepperidge farm as we were
going around the great smoky mountains
and this is a a very
completely true not made up story in the
slightest
there were uh
driving roads through the great smokies
and places you could park and you could
walk it was not as like rough as glacier
or north cascades it was you know it's
it's a bit more um
cultivated uh as far as national parks
go but at every one of these places
where there were trail heads there were
signs that said
nature awaits beautiful trails ahead
you don't just have to drive think about
parking and
and taking a walk
and there were signs literally at a
national park
urging people to please
park your car get out of your [ __ ]
car and walk around in the nature you
don't have to drive around the nature
you can walk around the nature and i
think about the planning meetings you
know the rangers like okay how we can
how we're going to get you know joe
smith out of his car how about a sign
how about a sign saying hey why not park
your car and take a walk yeah that's a
great idea
but um
i think that just it's hits your idea
they're square on the head edward abbey
who was a classmate of of wendell
berries
uh
famously in his book desert solitaire
talks about how
um he desperately
wanted in in the parks of utah
he wanted them not to put roads in you
know he said you
you got i understand that you have to
drive to the park
but but don't put roads in because
exactly that's what's going to happen
people are going to turn it into an
amusement park where you just drive
through and and maybe a bear will come
up to your car
well nick offerman this has been such an
enlightening conversation uh thank you
so much for
sharing your love of nature with us um
yeah we we love the book in your
incredible fifth book here
where the deer and the antelope play
with the extremely incredibly almost
impossibly handsome nick offerman
that is i would say an impossibly
handsome illustration of nick offerman
very chiseled thank you
but listen every every show nick on
metaphysical milkshake you've got to
know this we end the show
with a lightning round boom cue
lightning
life's biggest possible questions what
is america
our last best hope
what's something you could change about
yourself if you could uh less
gassy what is one eye-opening experience
every single person should have um go to
a prison and talk to
uh someone convicted of murder
if you could be mauled by any bear what
bear would you be mauled by
um
merlin olsen
he was a handsome bear
if you could have coffee or a beer
with a 19 year old nick offerman
what would you advise him
that one's always tough but it's a
lightning round so um
i would say
you have everything you need already
what happens to us after we die
hopefully uh we we you know
uh
decompose beautifully and and uh
continue this beautiful dance i'm hoping
to become a largemouth bass myself
two men
face to face with broadswords in a fight
who would win george saunders jeff
tweedy
ah boy i i feel like
i love that all of the questions
that we've thrown out about the universe
this is the one that stumped you this is
the lastness of the one i mean tweety
can you know he can handle an axe hey he
can but i think i think george i think
george uh he
he's secretly like he he has uh
deep uh nimble reserves
and then finally what is your life's big
question
am i am i giving more than i'm taking i
haven't heard that one that's a good one
and if you were that would be a good
thing yeah that's that's kind of what
i'm after is uh
emulating the selflessness of my mom and
dad um
i aim for a life of service
that's beautiful nick and these books
are a service and your writing is all of
your work
uh it's really inspiring as always we've
been
we've been chatting whether it's in an
audition room 20 years ago or
um now on a podcast uh it's just a
pleasure and a joy and a delight and um
you're an american
icon and um god bless you
well i appreciate it i i really am
grateful for the work you two do and i'm
grateful we can
have this conversation because that's
the goal
we can never stop having the
conversation because we'll
always keep screwing things up
so uh i'll look forward to next time
thank you nick we're the deer in the
antelope play folks get your hands on it
bye guys thank you
reza what do you think pretty inspiring
right i was that was kind of inspiring i
i sort of want to be like nick offerman
i wanna i wanna make a canoe you should
definitely make a canoe you know you
know what you could make a canoe out of
you can print out all the negative
tweets and hate comments about you
online
and then make a canoe out of that mold
them together into a canoe shape
yeah and just pray that it's waterproof
then it's win-win i will say this yeah
i've thought about it that conversation
with nick
i've changed my mind i want to go
camping with you i want to do the man
weekend man weekend no toilet paper
just me you
and the wilderness and the mud wrestling
we get to do the mud wrestling we'll get
we'll we'll do some mud wrestling just
we get to feel the wind and the hair on
our backs
i do have a lot of hair on my back so
yeah i think i think that'll work i only
have i have like 27 but man when they're
when they're stirred up i i just i feel
alive for the very first time uh what
about you uh metaphysical milkshake
listeners do you have hair on your backs
that's not the question i meant to say
uh what is your experience with nature
i mean do you have a great story about
hiking did did you did you uh listen to
what we were saying about the way that
uh nature can make you happier and
kinder and more generous do you have a
story like that or maybe even a horror
story about nature
we'll listen to those we like all the
stories we would love to hear your
life's big questions we'd love to hear
your thoughts on this podcast please
find us on social at reza aslan and
rayne wilson on twitter at
metamilkpodcast and on instagram at
metaphysical milkshake follow us please
retweet us re-post us please comment and
let us know your life's big questions we
may explore them on a future episode
milkshakers as you know when you rate
and review us on apple podcasts and you
ask
some big fascinating question and if we
find it to be interesting enough we ask
you to come on the show and ask us
personally and we have a milkshaker here
with us
victor from glasgow our very first
glaswegian
yes victor thanks for coming on the show
what's your question this is a question
that's that's can i come out of
my own experience of traveling all over
the states and my wife is american as
well and then i wanted that i wanted to
ask
what what is it particularly with
do you guys think with with white
americans particularly that there seems
to be a
blindness when it comes to american
patriotism
compared to the same kind of stuff that
goes on
in regimes around the world like north
korea etc because there is a large
degree of
brainwashing and the american patriotism
that we don't have here in the uk yeah
at all we're quite we're quite cynical
towards our governments and stuff if we
don't like mathemate we're just like
so yeah you know by but in the you know
the states is very sort of romantic and
the flag and all that kind of stuff so
and i have i have noticed that if you
have a conversation not everybody but
you have a conversation with some white
folks
regarding that stuff
it's like they can't see it they just
cannot see it but yet you compare
you know the the stuff that goes on in
the states to north korea or to any of
the these places around the world will
have dictators it's the same kind of
brainwashing i think put it that way
yeah in other words
uh there's a very fine line between
patriotism and fascism yeah exactly
exactly exactly yeah now do you think
victor there can be kind of a
a
healthy pride and love for one's country
yeah i think there can but i think that
i think as soon as
any country begins to believe
that it's the best in the world or
whatever and that's exactly that's
exactly what the british empire did you
know believed it was the best world and
uh you know look what it did
so i i think that's that's where it
turns from being healthy to being
you know
fascist i guess by the way it's not just
a right-wing trend here in the united
states you see it on the left wing as
well too this like
knee-jerk idea about how somehow the
united states is the greatest country in
the world
there is as i have said repeatedly on
this show there are only two literally
only two major categories in which the
united states ranks first
military and economy and that is
literally it we're not first in press
freedoms we're not first in democracy
we're not first in religious freedoms
you know so this idea you know i think a
lot of it is is fantasizing but yeah
here's kind of the the complexity of it
right which is that
there is something unique about the
united states in that
it is a very new nation state and unlike
the sort of nation states of europe
where the very concept of nationality
arose
the united states
never had the kind of
ethnic homogeneity
that gave birth
to
the european nation state in the first
place yeah right
we don't have a
the the founding of this country did not
come through
uh ethnic homogeneity or religious
homogeneity you know a
wide range of different protestant
denominations and catholics who settled
here you know early on there wasn't even
linguistic unanimity right because
people came from all over europe spoke
all kinds of different languages
and so
the founding of this country required
the invention
of brand new symbols
to rally around you know the flag
and this kind of you know divine you
know manifest that you know we that
americans were were um you know pursuing
and creating this country and then add
to that all the kind of religious patina
that was um settled over this the
founding of this country you know the
fact that you know we had people who
were fleeing religious persecution and
who came here the the rhetoric about
america being the new israel this is the
new chosen land you know god created
this land for these religious groups so
you you marry those two things together
the invention of brand new symbols to
rally around because we're not
ethnically religiously
uh or racially or linguistic
linguistically um you know homogeneity
homogeneous homogeneous major you've
been saying that word a lot
yeah and i've never even heard it before
you know you say it a few times and then
suddenly you're like is that even a word
homogeneity i think is a is a lovely
word anyway i might take it as my dj
name dj homogeneity
i thought it was so interesting i went
to europe
when i was really young and and i went
to um the netherlands and i was like oh
so what's your family a dutch yeah but
on your mom's side like the other
they're dutch what about on your dad's
side yeah they're dutch but and your
wife yeah her family's dutch so there is
zero zero melting pot uh that does not
happen here yeah everyone's a bunch of
mutts
i was in the netherlands uh some time
ago and i was talking to some dutch
friends and i don't even remember how
this came up but we were like blah blah
blah blah and i said something about the
pledge of allegiance and they said i'm
sorry the what
and i said oh
um
every single morning
in every
classroom
in the entire united states of america
school children stand up as one
face the flag put their hand over their
chest
and recite these words and i recited the
pledge of allegiance and their brains
exploded they were like what the [ __ ]
kind of crazy nazi fascism
is
they couldn't believe it it's pure
indoctrination yeah the thing is as well
you know being completely fair and
honest about all as well i mean it
wasn't that long ago that we would be
singing
god save the queen and all that and
there's a there's actually a verse at
the end of god save the queen that is no
longer sung that basically says in it
that we're basically bathing in the
blood of the scots
seriously seriously if you look up there
the original lyrics for god save the
queen is in there it's no longer sung
for obvious reasons but it's in there
well i think you know reza's talked
about this before but you know the
nation state the idea of a nation-state
is a pretty recent invention in in
humankind and i think you know
eventually we're going to have to move
to kind of
pride glory
um patriotism on
uh the human race on planet earth
and i know that's a very that's a very
baha'i point of view that's what we're
all about but um
uh baha'u'llah the founder of the baha'i
faith says glory not in this that you
love your country glory that you that
you love humanity and uh that's where
we're gonna have to move uh there might
be a handful of really tragic and
terrible wars on the way before we're
actually at that point
meanwhile
[ __ ]
[Applause]
now that that's a kind of patriotism a
city patriotism and pride that we can
get behind absolutely i still am a
complete hypocrite yeah
victor will you do everybody a favor and
will you just say the phrase they may
take our lives but they'll never take
our freedom
they may take our lives but they'll
never take our freedom
yes
yes that was terrible victor thank you
so much no problem folks as you know uh
please like us rate us review us
uh on apple podcasts if you leave a
fascinating and lovely question we would
love to bring you on the show unless
you're from edinburgh so follow us and
find us on social at reza aslan rayne
wilson and on twitter at metamilkpodcast
and instagram at metaphysical milkshake
let us know your life's big questions
and we would love to explore them on a
future episode we love you thank you
victor thanks for coming by
please don't forget to follow rate and
review metaphysical milkshake on apple
podcasts or wherever else you listen to
podcasts and of course you can always
subscribe to the metaphysical milkshake
youtube channel and watch our full
episodes every week if you watch today's
episode on the youtube channel you can
see that nick offerman for some reason
was doing his podcast from what i
imagine is a princess's bedroom did you
i think
either way we will see you next week uh
when we have a brand new episode of
metaphysical milkshake see you next week
rain thanks so much for tuning in
everybody
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it's produced by safa
samezadeh yaz harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell cast media is
the production and distribution partner
it is edited by tyler newbold and audio
mixed by joshua harris original music is
composed by jeff tang
the best bear advice i got when i was
camping was a ranger who said
look if you see a bear you should just
lie down and i was like well
but that seems dangerous like oh no he's
gonna he's gonna eat you he's gonna
probably kill you but you're better off
just lying down
[Music]
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you